all this week we're airing special
reports on tech tyranny looking at how
big tech companies are getting more and
more power and endangering a lot of
things that we think are important like
democracy and clear thinking here's
another example China's military is
obsessed with artificial intelligence
and is investing massive resources into
developing an advantage over our
military in artificial intelligence Eric
Schmidt shares alphabet that's the
parent company of Google he's admitted
that China will soon be the world's
leader in AI and they'll use it for
military purposes he's right maybe now
Google is dramatically expanding its
artificial intelligence research
operations in China which is bolstering
an effort that could eventually impair
the security of this country Paul share
is the author of army of none autonomous
weapons in the future of war which looks
like a horrifying book haven't ready yet
but I plan to Paul joins us thanks Bob
for coming in thanks for having me so
give us the the overview of this did did
I characterize it fairly do you think
look it's not surprising that Google's
looking to make research investments in
China China's got top two your AI talent
human capital is key here and they've
got access to a lot of data China will
have 20% of the world's data by 2020 and
data is the fuel that powers machine
learning and sort of a company like
Google they want they want access to all
that data so they've said yeah they've
every clue that there are standing up
more research in China and then it's
concerning for the United States morning
so I guess what I'm confused by is so
Google describes itself as a
multinational company really a kind of
corporation of the world but it was
incubated here and everything about
Google fundamentally is American it
wouldn't been possible to start Google
in China and yet Google doesn't seem to
feel any obligation whatsoever to the US
government or to the American people so
how does that work exactly look this is
this is capitalism I mean these
countries constable really these
companies responsible the shareholders
they're not accountable to the American
people and so they're gonna do it's in
their business interests and if there's
a business interest to move overseas to
stand up a research center the offshore
jobs they're gonna do that so American
taxpayers subsidize the edge
Asian of the people who fought who found
founded Google and who worked there and
we create the regulatory and legal
framework possible for it to start again
no other company like this has started
in Europe for example certainly not in
Asia so we make it possible and then
they turn around and undermine the
national security of the country I know
that people describe that as market
capitalism but that seems immoral to me
look at the end of the day we're in a
technology race and it's not just China
it's other countries as well
Vladimir Putin has said whoever controls
a I'll will lead the world France France
just released a new plan on artificial
intelligence we're gonna have to compete
we're gonna have to make the US an
attractive place for people to come and
invest and do AI research and found
companies to grow them and we're gonna
have to win this race by being faster
than others well here's another thing
that confuses me and since you've
covered it maybe you've got the answer
so companies like Google or big on
importing talent and they argue and I
understand why and they argue that we
just don't have enough engineers for
examples we need to bring H them in on
h-1b visas is there any thought by the
billionaires who run these companies hey
maybe we should take some of our
billions and invest in American
education this country isn't producing
an adequate number of scientists maybe
we could help with that or because they
feel no obligation to the country only
to their shareholders they don't feel
that I think some of these leaders do
you know you see Eric Schmidt the the
former chairman of alphabet goo fools
parent company was part of the Defense
Department's innovation Advisory Board
he has been very active in talking to
people at the Pentagon about how the
United States can retain its leadership
and artificial intelligence so some of
these leaders care really cuz Andrew
Carnegie put a library in every town in
America once he got rich here I don't
see any of these guys giving back really
in any way to the country they seem just
to be taking from it
call me left-wing I think I think a lot
of them could do more right and more
philanthropy from from billionaires
would be great yeah yeah it would be
great and we should demand it because
this country made their fortunes
possible I think Paul thank you for
coming on I appreciate it